[Musique]
pour
des jardins luxuriants des étangs cette
vision qui se décline sur tons de vert
et de bleu que l'on découvre à vol
d'oiseau n'est pas celle à laquelle on
s'attend de dubaï plutôt connue pour son
climat désertique suffoquant bienvenue à
la sustainable city la ville durable
une communauté qui fait le pari
d'harnacher l'énergie solaire et de
réduire sa consommation énergétique
pour nous le but principal c'est de
devenir ce qu'on appelle un net zéro
énergie c'est à dire que toute la ville
la ville durable nous aimerons nous
aimerions produire de l'électricité de
l'énergie du soleil à partir du soleil
pour pour alimenter toute la ville à
100%
quelques 26 mille panneaux solaires sont
distribués sur les toits de chacune des
500 villas des édifices publics et au
dessus des voitures dans les
stationnements chacun des aspects de la
construction des maisons réparties de
part et d'autre de ces rues parfaitement
paysager et entretenue a été pensé pour
minimiser l'impact du soleil et de la
chaleur qui peut facilement atteindre
les 50 degrés celsius ici orientation
plein nord aucune fenestration côté sud
vitrage anti-uv peinture réfléchissantes
tout ça permet à ces résidences de
consommer près de la moitié moins
d'énergie en climatisation qu'une
habitation moyenne à dubaï
les panneaux solaires qui sont installés
sur la terrasse fournissent aux
résidents entre 50 et 60% de l'énergie
dont ils ont besoin une économie
importante
cette villa au fait à sauver oui tonnes
de carbone sur une période de 18 mois
ce qui est pas mal ce qui est pas mal à
voir si on utilise sa part 500 et ça
commence à chiffrer rapidement dans les
rues les piétons et quelques vélos sont
rois les voitures sont interdites et
doivent rester au stationnement
communautaire la ville met à la
disposition des résidents des
voiturettes électriques
au début c'était un peu difficile parce
qu'on marche pas beaucoup à dubaï vous
savez au début c'est un peu choquant
spécialement quand ses 45 degrés d'or
mais ça va on s'habitue c'est ce petit
sacrifice que je fais mais à part ça au
contraire je trouve que je lis une vie
super belle ici
ce que j'ai gagné et c'est beaucoup plus
que ce que j'ai perdu céline son mari
emmanuel et leurs deux jeunes garçons se
sont retrouvés à sustainable city après
plus d'une dizaine d'année à dubaï mais
cherchait une façon de vivre autrement
la chose que j'aime le plus ici c'est la
communauté j'ai rencontré tellement de
gens intéressants sympathie c'est ça la
différence aussi les gens qui qui qui
décident de vivre ici sont déjà
intéressés par ce sujet d'écologie
l'environnement qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour aider notre planète j'ai
rempli ma bouteille dacquoise ozone
papier plastique dans les petits gestes
du quotidien céline a le sentiment de
pouvoir faire sa part pour freiner
l'effet des gaz à effet de serre sur
notre planète sur l'avenir de ses
enfants quand on parle de tout ce qui
est de développement durable il faut
vraiment pas il faut penser en société
il faut qu'il faut penser toujours en
communauté ce n'est pas l'individu elle
l'un vie de l'individu peut faire peut
faire beaucoup de choses mais c'est
c'est la communauté qui peut faire
davantage de choses ensemble
et alors si ça qu'on essaie de créer
sous chacun de ces dom la ville produit
des laitues des légumes et des herbes
qui sont distribués aux résidents
l'irrigation se fait avec les eaux usées
et recycler sur place on ne rien
gaspiller ici occupé à pleine capacité
sustainable city se concentrent sur
l'avenir
ses promoteurs veulent en faire un
centre mondial d'innovation des
technologies environnementales
c'est empilables c'est à dire que c'est
comme des boîtes de lego genre baudoin
est agronome chez agri coule une jeune
entreprise française qui veut
révolutionner l'agriculture en milieu
urbain avec ces conteneurs recyclés dont
la température et la luminosité sont
contrôlés pour y cultiver des fruits et
légumes à l'année ici ils produisent de
la fraise
c'est qu'on a vraiment le temps
d'attendre alors les récoltes à maturité
et on importe du coup aux consommateurs
quelques heures après la fraise mûre du
jour des fraises qui goûte l'été sur
toute une année une promenade au bord
d'un étang près duquel se reposent des
canards des rues où les enfants règne le
silence et une bonne conscience une
oasis une ville à échelle humaine
mais ce petit paradis est il à la portée
de tous le développement durable doit
toucher tout le monde je pense plus
qu'on a un choix ce n'est pas le luxe
qu'on essaie de vendre si c'est la
durabilité qu'on essaie de vendre et
alors pour que la vie durable soit
accessible à tout le monde
il faut que le coup le coup tout ce
qu'on voit ici autour de nous baisse
pour moi personnellement le concept de
vivre dans une communauté qui est en
train de faire une différence
ça valait la peine et je n'ai jamais
regretté ça mais oui il faut être riche
parce que ce qu'on paie là pour ceux
qu'on a un
on pourrait avoir beaucoup de russes
avec seront paix ou la même chose pour
moi beaucoup moins cher mais la qualité
de vie est incomparable